hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein
grundrezept von mir und zwar das rezept
für meinen schokoladigen bizkit boden
ihr braucht ihr euch wirklich nicht
fertig zu kaufen aus dem supermarkt der
hier ist schnell gemacht und schmeckt
viel besser das verspreche ich euch und
jetzt zeige ich euch die zutaten
wir benötigen ja ja die habe ich hier
aufgeteilt in eiweiß und eigelb außerdem
mehl zucker spalte stärke bei kakao hier
habe ich noch backpulver und eine prise
salz und damit wir später einen richtig
schönen lockeren bis geboten erhalten
stellen wir jetzt auf meine bc masse her
das machen wir indem wir das sommer
getrennte eiweiß jetzt in die schüssel
unsere küchenmaschine geben und da gebe
ich auch eine prise salz mit dazu das
bewirkt einfach dass die eiweiß struktur
schneller zerstört wird wenn wir wollen
gleich richtig flüssig aufschlagen soll
das gebe ich mit dazu und werde das
jetzt auf höchster stufe ungefähr 12
minuten angeschlagen
und jetzt ist die eiweiß meister schon
richtig weiß cremig geworden falls eure
schüsse jetzt nicht frei ist oder auch
euer schneebesen einsatz nicht frei war
oder was aber auch passiert dass es
manchmal ein eigelb mit drinnen ist zum
beispiel einfach nur ein tropfen dann
kann es auch schon passieren dass das
ganze nicht klappt und ihr diese weiß
man einfach nicht ausschlagen können
deswegen ist es wichtig dass es total
sauber und fettfrei ist und jetzt gebe
ich noch die hälfte des zucker sind so
schlank dass noch weitere ein bis zwei
minuten und dann haben wir eine richtig
feste biomasse
[Musik]
und nach zwei minuten ist die bitterste
fertig die ist richtig schön fest gleich
wenn diese unternehmen dann haben wir
nicht richtig schön diskret aber wir
brauchen jetzt neue schüssel das ist
ganz wichtig das gebe ich kurz an die
seite und mein schneebesen aufsatz den
benutze ich jetzt auch wieder in der
nächsten schüssel verrühren ich jetzt
eigelb mit dem restlichen zucker so
ungefähr zwei bis drei minuten dann auch
auf höchster stufe bis das ganze richtig
schön dick cremig ist
[Musik]
so und jetzt sieht man ganz deutlich
dass die masse richtig schön hell cremig
geworden ist und an der stelle geben wir
unsere weiß dazu also die gesehen hast
du wird es richtig schön sorgfältig
untergehoben und nimmt dafür bitte einen
teig schaber und kein schneebesen damit
die luft auch nicht ausgeht
[Musik]
die kasse wurde unter gehoben und jetzt
kommen die trockenen zutaten ins spiel
ich gebe das gerne noch mal durch einen
sie gebe einfach alle zutaten hier rein
dann kann man das noch mal ganz kurz vor
wenn man möchte und dann einfach rein 7
[Musik]
so die trockenen zutaten sind jetzt auch
in der schüssel und dann nehmen wir uns
wieder unseren teixeira und grünen das
noch mal ganz langsam unter
[Musik]
sobald wir dann wie trockenen zutaten
gut untergehoben haben nehmen wir uns
jetzt unsere springform oder einfach
drum ganz wie ihr möchtet dann einfach
mit backpapier auslegen und die seiten
nicht fetten und den teig anschließend
hineinfühlen und bei bedarf noch ein
bisschen glatt streichen
[Musik]
und unser vorbereiteter schoko biscuit
kommt jetzt in den vorgeheizten backofen
bei 180 grad ober und unterhitze für
circa 35 minuten je nach ofen kann es
aber auch variieren und 23 minuten
länger oder kürzer dauern
[Musik]
und nach dem backen dann den tortenboden
ganz einfach auskühlen lassen und nach
lust und laune und durchschneiden
befüllen mit was auch immer ihr möchtet
was ich daraus gezaubert habe das
verrate ich euch noch nicht ein bisschen
die spannung halten also schaltet auf
jeden fall im nächsten video erfahrt ihr
ist und die genauen mengenangaben
schreibe ich euch wie immer hier unten
in der infobox ich freue mich wenn in
diesem video and däumchen nach oben gibt
und meinen kanal kostenlos abonniert
dann verpasst ja auch nichts mehr
und übrigens kommt uns doch gerne auch
auf instagram unternehmen haben so und
ich euch auch gerne immer privat mit
ansonsten freue ich mich aufs nächste
mal mit euch
[Musik]